what do you mean by you got clear what
what what does that mean
the formula on what i want to do and how
i want to get there every formula to me
got clear okay like imagine right now
you want to leave and go to the airport
because you got to fly to that four
o'clock hypothetically right
if you don't know how to get there
you're spazzing out mm-hmm but if you
already know do you even think about
like in the interview have you been
worried about it at all thinking about
how you're going to get to the airport
because what's the first thing you're
going to do uber pick up you leave they
take you there you don't need to see
where i see what happens but if you
didn't know how to get to the airport
and you didn't know whether you're going
to make it past traffic in the middle of
the interview you're thinking about how
to get to the airport that's causing
anxiety
exactly the moment i figured out how i'm
going to get to from point a to point b
i said you know what
i'm good and i'm pretty crystal clear on
my next 15 moves wow so i don't have a
lot of thinking to do i'm solid we're
good to go